Buenas tardes Sí fue un discurso muy
emotivo lleno de referencias al héroe de
la Segunda Guerra Mundial el ex Primer
Ministro Winston Churchill ha dicho el
presidente
que Ucrania Está tratando de mantener
sus principios en las horas más oscuras
justamente haciendo referencia a la
lucha de Winston Churchill contra el
nazismo ha sido un discurso muy emotivo
el segundo aquí en la cámara de los
comunes el primero de manera personal y
agradecido al Reino Unido por todo el
apoyo brindado este país es uno de los
grandes aliados para Ucrania con ayuda
militar más de dos mil millones de
libras esterlinas y ha dicho zelanski
que desde el primer segundo desde la
invasión ucraniana el presidente también
ha hablado de la importancia de que haya
un tribunal para que se pueda juzgar los
crímenes de guerra cometidos por Rusia
ha dicho el mal sigue presente pero
vamos a saber Cómo se siente el momento
de la Victoria pero todos los días
estamos pagándolo con vidas y con
lágrimas ha pedido también al Reino
Unido que de más apoyo militar no
solamente este país está dando
entrenamiento sino recursos millonarios
como les digo Pero además se espera que
hoy el Primer Ministro hago oficial que
el Reino Unido va a dar
entrenamientos de pilotos de combate y
también para Infantería de Marina como
parte de ese apoyo como les digo ha sido
un discurso muy emotivo es el ensky ha
hecho referencia a su primera visita
como presidente en el 2020 y habló de
cómo se ha transformado desde entonces
su vida lo vimos dirigirse a las dos
cámaras del parlamento la House y la
House of commons vestido con su uniforme
militar que se ha convertido en ese
emblema desde que inició la ocupación
rusa y Esta visita es bien importante el
día de hoy Porque es la manera en que se
lensky recibe apoyo por supuesto muy
importante del Reino Unido pero también
que le dice al mundo no tengo miedo no
tenemos miedo especialmente que le dice
a Rusia es bien importante también la
referencia que ha hecho el presidente a
la relación con el Rey Carlos III
hablando justamente de ese pedido
especial que está haciendo No solamente
al Reino Unido sino a todos los países
que pueden hacerlo dar apoyo con aviones
ha dicho que el Rey Carlos tercero tiene
una relación bien importante con la
Fuerza Armada de este país y que cada
piloto ucraniano es un rey porque hay
tan pocos en ese país y eso impulsando
aún más su mensaje de la importancia de
que para poder ganar esta guerra que ha
dicho no tenemos duda de que lo van a de
que la vamos a ganar necesitan
urgentemente aviones de combate han
dicho que los soldados toman riesgo y
también ha hecho referencia al
entrenamiento que alrededor de 30.000
militares en los últimos seis meses
militares
ucranianos han recibido aquí en
territorio británico y justamente esta
tarde selensky y el Primer Ministro hizo
una visitarán una de esas zonas para
revisar Cuál es el entrenamiento que se
le está dando a los que se a los
operarios a los soldados que serán los
encargados de los tanques challenge to
que el Reino Unido anunció que entregará
es bien importante también lo que dice
el presidente que es importante la
protección de los Derechos Humanos en
esta Guerra de Ucrania que nos recordó
Cada día que sigue presente